Meditation.
Spirituality is the key to unlock human potential.
It's a perfect example of how inequality emerges.
And we've seen this with test as well.
You know,
I've always wanted to build my own software company saying pretty much they cost
autonomous.
It's just getting over that last little bit of do we really have the regulatory
and the social infrastructure to support switching vehicles to autonomy.
Everybody's equal to begin with.
Everybody basically plays a random game cause monopolies basically around them
games.
We're instead of having huge amounts of corn,
soybean ground to feed all these farm animals and massive slaughter plants then
and forums you then we'll just have basically your own localized queen meat
production.
The court is written by the programmers and the artists create the visuals.
So what does a designer do have and designers at all?
They started to mentally think of the player and to make that experience be as
enriching as possible.
So it's a random game.
So what happens when everyone starts equal and you play a random game?
One person ends up with everything.
Everyone else stacks up at zero where they sold the company just before I turned
24.
Oh yes.
That is what I'm talking about.
Well,
what do you ask?
Uh,
you know,
children,
what they want to be when they grow up.
Mine was like an inventor or like,
you know,
I want to know when to stop wearing them.